in this episode of cloud performance
atlas we help a cloudy developer get
clarity into tracing and high instance
counts does the forecast call for sunny
skies stay tuned to find out an old
friend of mine recently launched a new
image service called partly cloudy which
provides high resolution images of
clouds for developers who need to use
them in professional presentations after
week of launching her open beta she woke
up one morning to see this little gem
waiting for her in the Google cloud
Developer console the blue line in this
graph charts the number of active app
engine instances that the application is
using these numbers are really high
considering the applications only job is
to grab an image and send it to the user
but the developer of partly-cloudy had a
hunch she was seeing really high latency
numbers in the trace results and was
assuming that this was responsible for
the high number of instances in some
cases high response time can cause new
instances to be spun up so after looking
at this list of traces I had to agree
this looked like the obvious problem
however when I dug into the tracing
information things started to get really
weird the latency was being reported as
six seconds but the trace information
said that the sum of all RPC calls was
only taking about a hundred and eighty
milliseconds now while digging in more
things started to get wacky I added some
custom tracing code around the entire
response section which showed us that
there was no rogue code executing and
taking up time things were happening
really fast the big issue here though
was that we weren't seeing the huge six
second delays the logs were showing from
before in fact any repo I tried it
didn't seem to exhibit the same slow
performance numbers even when submitting
the exact same HTTP request the
breakthrough came when I looked at the
logging information for the slower
request it was coming from a mobile
device this gave me an idea what if the
connection speed was causing the trace
numbers to be inflated disasters Theory
out I throttled my connection speed with
a few curl commands which you can also
do in chrome dev tools and got the
following timings sadly still no changes
when dealing with really odd
discrepancies like this it's sometimes
good to take a break so we grabbed some
tacos
when we came back we found that our
quizzical error had gotten even more
complex the traces which had low-latency
before suddenly had a higher value in
the tracing list after another 30
minutes it seemed that the graph had
updated with these new numbers then I
remembered something sitting between
user connections and your App Engine
instance is a series of App Engine front
ends these front ends will act as a
liaison between the client and the given
instance when the App Engine instance is
done processing a requests the data is
passed back to the front end which stays
connected to the client as long as it
takes to transfer the data while this is
happening the App Engine instance can be
off servicing other requests now what
this means to you is that regardless of
how slow the client connection is it's
not going to impact your instance count
now it makes sense that then that there
will be a slight delay in the traces
receiving and updating this information
I mean there's lots of complex steps
here and all that data has to be
gathered and presented properly to the
tracing tool more importantly this means
that partly-cloudy since tense count was
not a function of connection speed or
weird code issues turns out the reason
for the high instance count was
resounding success when we flipped over
to the traffic graph we saw that over
the past six hours people have been
using the partly-cloudy service really
aggressively partly-cloudy was a victim
of its own success but still the
instances are too high and now that we
knew that there wasn't some weird code
issue we could get to bringing that
number down it turns out that partly
cloudy Zarqa texture was really part of
the problem in their setup App Engine
will handle the request from a client do
an NDB query to the datastore which
contains info on all the 20,000 images
available from there the instance will
randomly pick one
fetch the full image from the GCS bucket
sent it along back with its details to
the client the solution then is
straightforward let's find a way to
spend less time having the clients talk
to App Engine and more time having them
ping GCS buckets directly which meant
changing the access pattern when the
client fetches an image from GAE append
the next 10 images ID as an extra header
in the field the client will then fetch
the next 10 images directly from GCS
rather than needing to go through GAE 4
when we're out of prefetched images go
back to the server and grab the next
batch when we flipped over to this code
the results were better than expected an
8-hour run saw an instance count dropped
from about 16 instances on average to
about 1.5 see that's the trick with
performance improved
you have to eliminate all the
possibilities before really
understanding the problem and to learn
more about all the possible ways that
perf can go sideways check out the rest
of the cloud performance Atlas videos
and remember when it comes to
performance every millisecond counts